[Music]
if you go back to kiten n we know we had
a force on the head wrapping around me
and we know we had a force on his comen
on the on the bottom side of his lever
going in the different direction of that
and we know that we had a force that
moved that whole
foot do you understand it's going this
[Music]
way a point we have to make is that
although it looks like I'm I'm going
flat on this circle I don't want to do
that because going to activate the
outer now your ego Tri Ty mind is going
to go oh arm arm break here you get it
so you're thinking hyp extension you
feel that and then either he goes or I'm
going to break his arm right so you go
like you're thinking
that do you understand that's not it
going to be a
part where between this pressure you see
and this enter here I have him locked in
place
okay Bo I'm going to move in here I'll
push this leg out so this this leg will
come on my kind of
cushy what
I'm
get who this
continuous